[Musique]
avec du beurre de la confiture au petit
déjeuner pendant le repas à midi ou
encore avec de la pâte à tartiner au
goûter le pop est un élément
incontournable de notables et pourquoi
ne pas le faire vous-même
mélanie poquet s'est rendu dans un
atelier tout spécialement pour les
enfants
bonjour madame bonjour camille je suis
pas allée très loin parce que j'ai été
tout près de saint quentin en yvelines
aux fermes de gally à saint cyr l'école
à chaque vacances scolaires les
week-ends ou les jours fériés
les équipes proposent un atelier pain et
toute la famille est invitée à mettre la
main à la pâte festive ans puisque dès
le plus jeune âge des trois ans on peut
s'y mettre
ça commence à trois ans on peut le faire
jusqu'à ses 12 ans alors une vingtaine
d'enfants peut participer à chaque
atelier
ils vont faire toutes les étapes de la
création de son propre pain l'animateur
commence avec une explication des
produits avec en plus un ancrage local
parce que la farine l'eau la levure
vienne est désigné c'est important que
les enfants des cousins tatuya parce que
le plan nous en mangeons tous les jours
alors fait découvrir les différentes
céréales donc qui peut aussi avec aussi
du touch et donc aussi pour découvrir la
matière est aussi surtout de d'où
proviennent les produits qui viennent
forcément de la terre qu'il faut la
protéger aussi il n'y a pas que la main
à la pâte est aussi très important donc
de savoir le 2 2 sont les origines est
produit l atelier dure 45 minutes mais
il ne concerne que la pâte crue a en
effet le pain sera cuit à la maison mais
pas d'inquiétude l'animateur remet à la
fin de l'atelier aux parents une recette
notamment à propos de la cuisson mais
lors de cet atelier il y a plusieurs
étapes rigolote la première bien sûr
c'est de mélanger les produits certains
ont même cru à de la pâte à modeler j'en
ai vu d'autres tentés de goûter avec le
sel c'est pas toujours très bon pas
cuisse et pas assez parce qu'elle
meilleur au goût
et puis on rentre à la maison il ya une
petite étape qui est super intéressante
à regarder c'est regarder la pâte levée
sous l'effet de la levure avant de la
mettre au fond
ça plaît bien nous enfants écouter les
camps là c'est la page il est bien
il fallait bien étiré et après il y
avait les trous et après c'est moi
j'aime bien plié après c'est c'était
très dépendants maintenant je sais aider
parce qu'on a une machine à faire du
vent alors les ateliers ont lieu trois
fois par jour lors des vacances
scolaires à les week-ends et jours
fériés comme je disais tout à l'heure le
tarif 3 euros 80 mais c'est toujours le
plaisir de goûter son propre pain et si
jamais vous n'êtes pas attiré par
l'atelier pain il est aussi un atelier
beurre et d'autres rendez-vous sont
aussi proposées autour de la nature et
des animaux
l'occasion aussi d'en profiter pour
visiter la ferme et ses pensionnaires
merci mais l'alliance que nous allons
reparler de cet atelier et pour plus de
renseignements rendez vous sur le site
internet et on